hi many people have participated in the
daily community questions we have on our
youtube community tab and one thing was
appearing over and over and over again
well if only there was someone bored
enough to help with that to create
videos around these machine learning
quiz questions we're posting over there
hi there my name is tim and i'm
currently doing my phd on machine
learning mostly centered around
geometric and medical data
first of all please note that this video
is most likely not 100 correct perfectly
accurate or in any other way beyond
doubt or different interpretation if you
find something that you disagree with
please do argue with us in the comments
just as letizia i'm just a phd student
not someone who can even remotely claim
to know everything besides i don't think
someone like that even exists and even
the best make mistakes
and i'm far from the best
so leticia put out a question about ein
faces while an eigenface can just be
seen as a weird german english mixture
word and fun fact we call these mutant
words denglish in german it's also a way
of analyzing faces
and while eigenfaces are some more
classical computer vision invented long
before the dominance of neural networks
they are still pretty interesting the
idea is to describe a given phase
through a combination of fixed
components to be more exact a linear
combination of some bass face pieces so
to get leticia's face you could
recombine the face pieces from the
learned base to actually form her face
so how do we do that for a given input
collection of faces you represent them
as vectors then you compute the
principal component analysis of this
data basically obtaining the most
important vectors that you need to
properly express the faces in the
collection as a linear combination
so for our faces given as a set of
vectors here just shown with two
dimensions because drawing a hundred
thousand dimensions gets somewhat
cumbersome we compute the covariance
matrix then compute the first k
eigenvectors that we can then use as a
basis to approximate any input phase
vector and this is why we call these
base faces the eigenfaces because they
are phase components computed from
eigenvectors of the covariance matrix of
all the faces these eigenfaces can then
be used for things like real-time face
detection while they are still somewhat
fast and robust at least when you
compare that to other approaches that
are not deep learning based
for the next question i want to
summarize what domain adaptation is and
for clarity also what transfer learning
is in general and how that differs
while that is a bit of a fuzzy
definition we can generally say that
domain adaptation happens when one
solves the same task but changes the
kind of input the task requires for
example we train to detect dogs in an
image during the day
and after domain adaptation we still try
to detect dogs but perhaps now with
images taken during the night
we just have a different but still
related input data distribution
this domain adaptation is part of what
is called transfer learning for transfer
learning not only the domain can change
but the task itself can also change we
repurpose a model trained on one task to
be used on a different one so what
actually changes during domain
adaptation between settings
well we just swap out the data
distribution of the input and as you can
already imagine the difference whether
something is just domain adaptation or
already learning a different task is
somewhat flimsy and up for debate
where is the line in all this is
detecting dogs at night already a
different task is detecting cats so much
different that it's not just a different
data distribution but essentially a new
task
let's move on to another one which is
trying to find out how you see one of
the latest trends in machine learning
you are asked whether you believe that
causality will be the next big thing
in machine learning and roughly half of
you thought so
so what is causality in ml about and why
do we need it
well machine learning is terrible at
knowing causal relationships for example
when it is raining there are more people
outside holding umbrellas without more
information a machine learning algorithm
looking at images could also come to
think that using umbrellas actually
causes it to rain the machine learning
algorithm doesn't know how our world
works it just detects patterns and
correlations and not cause our
relationships and correlation is not
enough to establish causality
well how do humans overcome this
with trying things out does it start
pouring if you pull out your umbrella
while the sun is shining
well no it will only cause people to
stare at you weirdly but that is exactly
the problem
this trying out which is called an
intervention in causality context is
somewhat generally machine learning
doesn't do
machine learning is not embodied and
generally cannot act to generate their
own training data it just looks at data
and makes up statistical predictions
detects patterns it does not try things
out to find causal relationships so why
is that even important if we just want
to make some predictions on known data
we are fine without causality but as
soon as we want to use deeper
understanding of the domain and find
truly invariant features like by
suggesting actions we need to learn
casual structures and not just
statistical correlations we may not want
our house robot of the future to
actually have to drop our favorite vase
to find out that dropping it causes it
to break and not breaking it causes it
to drop
if you want to dive deeper into the
topic we will leave you the link to a
great talk in the description box below
and rather leave the technical parts to
the experts
and in case that was nothing new to you
what do you think let us know in the
comments whether after transformers
being one of the latest big trends now
causality is all you need i sincerely
apologize for his behavior
and lastly we have two questions that
are somewhat related first of all
letitia wanted to know what the manifold
hypothesis actually is
so a manifold for starters is any
topological space where the surroundings
of each point are similar to the
euclidean space more simply put it's a
space where for every local point we can
describe its neighborhood through a
chart which is just a flat
representation for example for a sphere
like the earth or a coffee mug if we
zoom in enough we have a flat surface
that we can create a map for we can no
longer see the curvature
so this is a manifold now the manifold
hypothesis actually states that complex
data from the real world like photos or
handwritten digits that is high
dimensional data with lots of pixels can
be compressed into a lower dimensional
form
what that means is that for these 28 by
28 pixel wide handwritten digits we can
express all plausible handwritten digits
through far less values than these 28 by
28 color values for example we could
reduce that to some information on what
handwritten digit it is and some piece
of information that describes how thick
and skewed and so on this number is in
result we'd get a representation that's
probably a lot lower dimensional than
the 784 dimensions of our pixel space
so we then have a low dimensional
representation of our data that lies in
the high dimensional image space this
lower dimensional structure this more
simple representation
that is the data manifold and what
happens to the rest of the high
dimensional space well it is populated
with data that does not make sense in
the real world in the image space this
was consists of all the images that are
pure noise in all configurations in
other words the manifold hypothesis
tells us that natural data is more
structured and constrained than one
would expect that the possibilities to
generate implausible non-existent data
points are far more numerous than
natural data which has a certain
simplicity attached to it
so to summarize the manifold hypothesis
just states that real-world data like
these handwritten digits is actually
lower dimensional than the original real
world space it lives in here the 784
pixel values and the same of course also
holds for more complex examples like
pictures of cats or representations of
geometry
a question tightly linked to the
manifold hypothesis is on what the
denoising outer encoder actually does
for denoising autoencoder you train an
autoencoder on some data that is you
feed data through a neural network that
at some point has a smaller capacity
than your input and then you try to keep
as much information alive as possible
now this should already sound somewhat
familiar to the manifold hypothesis an
autoencoder with a small bottleneck
learns a lower dimensional
representation of the input data
a noisy outer encoder then gets an input
that is actually corrupted for example
for handwritten digits we apply some
noise to the image pixels
when we then encode and decode that and
now train such that the outer encoder
does reconstruct the input this is
removing some part of the noise because
for the high dimensional input of this
image only the lower dimensional part
with actual meaning the part without the
noise the real data manifold is actually
learned and that is because it is just
way more complicated to learn random
noise patterns rather than meaningful
data and it is much more complicated to
fit that through the tiny bottleneck and
formally speaking what this actually
does for example is to learn the
manifold of plausible handwritten digits
here inside the bottleneck and for a
noisy input that's not on that manifold
the encoding process then just projects
that back onto the learned manifold
because that is all the auto encoder can
actually memorize and by then decoding
that we get a less noisy input there's
some great and easy to understand paper
in the description below with some more
thoughts about the manifold go check
that out
we hope that this was somewhat
interesting and useful to you and i'd
love to get some feedback and some
discussions below in the comments you
can also suggest new community questions
in the comments so that these become a
bit more diverse in the future thank you
very much for watching and see you in
another video hopefully thanks tim